as you went through the early days of
the internet there's a lot of
similarities and a lot of differences to
what we're seeing right now what are the
similarities you see between the early
days of the internet and kind of the
proliferation of that the adoption from
consumers and then what i'll just call
the crypto industry today are there
specific things that jump out to you is
like yup this is just the playbook all
over again some things are similar like
the early internet um was really just
text and it was academic and researchers
and then used that which was a news
group system and then with netscape we
did a commercial version of a browser
that you could trust to send your credit
cards over the wire with and
that took off and took over from the
sort of
academic
front runner mosaic and one of the
things that's similar is that you have
early adopters who are actually
programmers so they're giving you ideas
sometimes they're giving you code if you
do open source or they're they're doing
hacks on their servers that
then generate new ideas that you put
into the client so even before netscape
the image element was added to html
before 1993 you couldn't do an image you
had to have some kind of crazy plugin
and all those early plugins died you
remember flash this was way before flash
and then in in 1995 i did javascript so
we had images in javascript and you
could do
simple things with
animations in the bottom of the browser
or in texts or text inputs
but it was still pretty limited so in
1996 we had the ability to replace
images but all this stuff was fed by the
early elite users who were themselves
developers and i see similarities with
web3 where you have this sort of back
and forth between users of a project and
core team or contributors to the project
sometimes they overlap sometimes there's
just fast flow of innovative ideas
because anybody can have a good idea and
that is critical if you just pretend you
can grand plan this all like you're
doing the ibm
you know um 360 mainframe it's not gonna
work yeah by the way that was such a
flex like yeah i helped bring images to
the internet i appreciate that we we all
like memes and images here so your
your work is uh very very fast
replacement yeah mark andreas and eric
biena did images in 1993 but i did the
javascript that lets you flip them
around change it oh even better all
right what are the what are the big
differences that you see between the
early days of the internet and today
so early internet
was still uh kind of a big company game
after netscape kicked it off
in the web i would call the web one era
and you so you had uh microsoft come
after netscape that's a story i've told
before you had the big server-side
powers that rose in the late 90s like uh
amazon was mid-90s when it started and
paypal
was was coming up right around the
millennium end
and uh you know google was actually
there in 1998 i remember seeing them
above palo alto bicycles in downtown
palo alto and i wonder what those
childish letters and colors were all
about um
and you know around 98 or 99 we were all
and that stayed using google we realized
it was going to totally
kill all the other search engines like
alta vista so you know
you see now people talk about big crypto
powers like coinbase finance you know
ftx and others
i think that's just the current guard
and the guard will change you'll have
new powers rise and one of the things
we're interested in brave is
self-custody because it's it sounds like
it's too scary for most people i can
talk about why that's probably not the
case anymore but back then
when these network powers rose like
paypal or google eventually people were
learning how to log into a website they
could learn to log into their bank in
the mid late 90s and they'd recover
their password if they forgot it they'd
use the same password all over the web
which was a security disaster but you
know 25 years later we finally got
sort of a handle on this with
apple and others generating email
address per site for you to log into
so you don't get this sort of honeypot
problem with one email address and one
password used all over your password
manager is built into the operating
system like keychain again apple has or
others or you have one password which i
use so so we finally took 25 years we
finally got people learning how to sort
of semi securely log in and there's
still a lot of people that are just
popped through you're using a password
or spelling the password uh or there's a
server-side breach but uh i think what
we're doing with crypto is going to move
toward a more secure model and it may
not be that much harder maybe actually
better